all right Savannah
hello Savannah where are you from
originally where'd you grow up uh Dayton
Ohio Dayton tell me about your family
um well my parents split up when I was
two my mom and dad
um and then she got with my stepdad at
when I was three and they were both
addicted to meth crack and alcohol so
you can imagine
um there was a lot of like verbal abuse
physical abuse
um
my mom told me to kill myself a lot
things like that uh at what age huh at
what age oh yeah I mean the abuse
started at three I remember my stepdad
has thrown me down a flight of stairs at
three years old
I mean I have memories that go back as
far as three years old that's when she
got with him
um and he would you know he threw me
down the stairs
um if I were to cry if I was sick or
hungry or you know basic necessities is
like a child I would get beaten so I
wasn't allowed to like have a voice or
and if I did have a voice I would get
beaten and that's just how it went were
you and only on the child I was an only
child I was supposed to be I'm not
supposed to be here right now my mom
wanted to abort me and she would tell me
that all the time I wish I would have
aborted you but
um
you know whatever I mean it doesn't like
my childhood doesn't like bother me it's
like I just I just kind of like try to
like not think about it really you know
but um but yeah so that's how that went
up until I was 15 and I'll never forget
this moment
um it's when
I fought back because I mean I was just
getting
I was taking all this abuse for no
reason it's my parents they hated
themselves or I don't say my parents is
my mom my stepdad my dad is lovely like
he's my best friend I'm lucky to have
him but um was he in your life yeah I
talk to him every day okay
um and he's never been an addict so you
know and he yeah he's my best friend but
um they hated themselves they hated
their lives and I feel like I was kind
of like their punching bag and it just
wasn't fair in one day I just lost my
[__] and I I kick I I beat the [__] out
of my mom and I it was one of the most
honestly like liberating moments in my
life it really was and I'm not ashamed
to say that
um I kicked her in the stomach and she
flew into the wall and she
put a hole in the wall That's How
intense it was my rage had just and it's
like I was numb to all emotions at this
point because I had had all of this like
just cruel abuse for no reason so like
the only emotion I had in my body at
that age
um was rage and it all came out and she
tried to call the cops on me but she was
so intoxicated and high on whatever she
was high on and
um I sat calmly so the cops you know the
cops didn't believe her I didn't she
tried to get me like locked up for that
and the second time the second person I
had to deal with was my stepdad and he
was a whole different Beast um
but I had I knew I had to stand up to
him too I had to put an end to this I
had to make them scared of me
um I scared my mom she stopped [__]
with me
um my stepdad
um he was a very very scary person
he would he was the one who did most of
the beatings like the brutal brutal
beatings like I had to cover my body
there was one time where my leg this
whole thigh this whole like this big
like this the whole thigh was welted
black blue purple raised I mean it was
it was terribly beat me with the shoe I
mean like so he was a different thing I
had to deal with and I came in one day I
had a broken foot
and um
it might you could see my foot was
broken it was like Twisted sideways and
I had my boyfriend at the time this was
in high school and my boyfriend at the
time he was carrying me in I was seven
minutes past curfew and he's like give
me your phone blah blah at this point I
had a knife under my pillow because I
was getting I was I like I said I was
filled with so much [__] rage
at this point and I was just ready to
just unfuckingly she know what I mean I
didn't have any other emotions and so um
I had a knife under my pillow at this
point because I knew the time would come
where he would get all cracked out and
come and try and you know do what it do
what he does and so I go into my room
and he's like he's like you're grounded
give me your phone I'm like no I'm not
giving you my phone he's and he tries to
come at me per usual he's always trying
to come at me hit me to hit me in my
face I mean it didn't even [__]
matter you just just
it's complete miserable yeah and so I
um
basically I pulled the knife out I stood
on top of my bed because he's a tall man
so I had to I stood on top of my bed
with the knife and I said
um get the [__] away from me I'm not to
be [__] with I will never I will never
be [__] with get the [__] away from me
you you like you have no [__] right
to be doing what you're doing right now
and I put my phone in my pants so he
could because he was never like I was
never molested by him or anything like
that but I did come to find out a couple
months ago that he is a pedophile
but to little boys not to girls so
that's why he never molested me so
um so that that's just that was like my
childhood and then at 16
um I was diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder which will Pro
which probably explains a lot of the
crazy stuff that I you know uh had done
later in life
um but
yeah I was diagnosed with borderline I
moved in with my dad luckily my dad like
and his and my stepmom was like the
mother I never had she did my room I had
never had my room done in my life I
lived in squalor before like it was just
absolute just disgusting I never had
friends over it was embarrassing
um but my stepmom was like the mother I
never had I moved in with them
um but I did have borderline and I did
have medication for it but I didn't take
it seriously
um I was 16 and my stepmom would give me
my my medication every day and I would
be like
um oh yeah I'm gonna take it I'm gonna
take it and take it I'd flush it on
toilet so I never took it seriously and
I never even cared to really know what
it was but I think
when I you know later in life I got
diagnosed again but that's later that's
later but I'm just saying like
I think that had a lot to do with my
behavior because I did have a lot of
outbursts
they came out of nowhere I would go on
random
I think I'm getting ahead of myself I
started drinking at 17. I didn't drink
all through high school I had no
interest in drinking because my
my family just seeing how they acted and
at that time you know I thought it was
just alcohol but you know come to find
out it was crack and meth you know what
I mean so
um
I didn't have an interest in drinking or
I wasn't curious about it but I met a
friend senior year and um
she was a party girl really pretty
whatever and she's really nice and she's
like come drinking tonight come out and
I was like I was like I don't drink
she's like come on you know and I'm like
oh I'll think about it I went out had a
drink it was it was it for me
um you know after the alcohol like after
one sip of alcohol
it was like that was just it it's kind
of like how people explain their first
head of heroin
you know and I've done here I'll get to
that that's later I'm getting too ahead
of myself but
um
I've done every drug and I'm nothing
affected nothing did it for me like
alcohol my first drink of alcohol
was like it felt like a warm hug from
the universe like the answer to all my
[__] prayers and
um it was just like I'm like oh my God
I it just I felt like it was solved all
my problems I drank a whole bottle my
first time and that's how it was ever
since then ever since
you know since the beginning it was just
I never drink normally ever I once I
started I could not stop and I didn't
get sick at first until like later on in
life I didn't get sick from the alcohol
I didn't have complications from it
I had a you know good you know life and
then at I don't remember if I was 17 or
18.
I think I think I was like I think I was
17 about to like write on the like about
to be 18. when I'm literally packed a
bag overnight and decided I was going to
move to LA
why La I don't know because I didn't
know anybody out here but I was curious
I was drawn to like dark things
like not like bad like
I don't explain it like things that are
like mysterious and dark and I always
saw like this lifestyle you know I'm not
saying LA's like a dark lifestyle but it
there is a part of it that is and so I
was always curious about getting into
like dark and mysterious things you know
what I mean I was always attracted to
darker the darker side of things and so
I just wanted to experience life I
didn't want to go to college
um that's why I dropped out I knew that
I did not want to spend my youthful
years
um just going to college for something I
didn't even give a [__] about I just
wanted to party I wanted to live I
wanted to do what I wanted
and so that's why one day like this is
actually kind of nuts I mean this is I
mean this kind of goes back to the
borderline thing this is like some
borderline [__] if you think about it
like I One Night in my head there wasn't
really a thought in my mind at all
actually doing this I just get my
um I get my phone out get a plane ticket
to LAX I have I know nobody there I've
never been on a plane before didn't know
anybody like didn't have any connections
like nothing I think I had like 500 to
my name
and I just literally one morning I go
downstairs with my dad and I'm like Dad
I'm like can you drive me to LAX he's
like or sorry not LAX oh my God I was
like can you drive me to the airport and
he's like he's like yeah uh he's like
why and I was like I'm going to La and
he's like what business do you have
being in La I'm like I don't know I'm
just gonna go he's like what are you
gonna do I'm like I'll figure it out I
figure everything out you know like
and so I got to La I he took me my dad
supports most the stuff I do not not
everything but he pretty much knows
everything about me
um but
yeah so I get to LAX I get the only
thing I was worried about was a plane
ride because I'd never been on a plane
so that was what I was tripping I was
like oh my God I'm getting I don't want
to get on this like plane it's like a
floating tube in the sky like it's so
scary like
that's all I was worried about I wasn't
worried about going to LA with no money
um but when I arrive at LAX there's a
man in the airport and he approaches me
and he's like
um
hi like
um do you want to go to dinner and I
told him like I'm bulimic I don't want
to go to dinner like I'm like I don't
there's no point I'm just gonna puke it
all up and he's like oh well that's hot
and I'm like
I'm like all right you la people are a
little bit of a different breed but
whatever so I'm like yeah sure I'm like
but I'm just gonna vomit at it so it's
like he's like I like that that's hot
I'm like
I'm like all right let's go so we go to
dinner and then he said he would take
care of me and all this [__] you know
how guys are they're just like yeah I'll
take care of you I'll do this and then
he didn't do [__] like yeah I lived in
his house it didn't last long so by this
time I am 18 I go to a hotel or I was
there for probably like I don't know two
months or something and it was like it
felt like years it was horrible
um
and then I went to uh I've just
sporadically moved out one day I
couldn't take it anymore I was just like
I just I just don't like this guy he was
into some weird sexual Kinks
um that I don't even know if I could
mention because they're really they
might be like triggering to some people
but let's just say they were really
weird sexual uh Kinks
um that aren't funny
um so I just couldn't take it and so I
moved to a motel by myself didn't tell
him
and I was like [__] I had no money at
this point and no way home the the motel
was like 50 bucks so like I'm like all
right this is like the last of my money
I called my dad and my dad's like no
he's like you he's like you know you're
a Survivor like you should just you know
um go and and you should figure it out
and I'm like
[__] man like because I could I couldn't
get home like I had no way home I mean I
maybe could have taken a bus or
something but like [__] that no so I'm
just like kind of brainstorming by this
time I'm 18 I could do you know sex work
I could do you know that
and I had been objectified by a lot of
men in my life so I was kind of knew
that like that would probably be what I
was gonna do so I um
I saw some pink flashing lights down the
street from this motel and I'm like oh
what's that and so I I walked down there
and it's a [__] strip club and I'm
like hmm I'm like okay so I go so I go
to the strip club I just walk in and I
had no stripper clothes I barely I
didn't close at all because I left
everything behind in Ohio I didn't give
a [__]
um and so I walk and I'm like hi I'm
looking for a job they're like you got
it I'm like like I didn't even have to
try out or anything and they're like
we're open from 11AM to 4 a.m so I
worked from 11AM to 4 a.m every day
almost and I stacked up quite a bit of
money all I had was a bikini from Target
I didn't even have stripper clothes but
I still went in and did it and my first
night I made like 1200 give or take
something like that I'm like damn I'm
like and
for me like I
it wasn't dark for me I liked the I
liked being objectified in a weird way
because you know growing up I felt like
my parents never gave me the attention
that I wanted
so you know when I when I was being
objectified and you know praised by you
know these men like it made me feel like
I was kind of on a high horse in a way
or like it made me feel really good and
so it was kind of addicting and the
money of course is addicting and I was
like I'm making money just by like and
I'm being like you know it's just like
it was just like a thing I I liked it
you know and um
so that was that that was the stripping
it was pretty good money I stocked up
for about a week and then I'm thinking
ahead I'm like you know what I could do
more I could do more you know it's like
because at this point in my life I had
already
you know been promiscuous and Reckless
you know I did a lot of crazy [__]
um because of the alcohol I was a
full-blown Alcoholic by the way through
all this and I was anorexic and bulimic
so that's not really the best
combination I wouldn't recommend it
um but um I wasn't on like drugs yet
that didn't happen until I started like
actual sex work
um but alcohol is a drug and it did
destroy me the most out of everything
um so I
get so I'm getting on the sugar daddy
size I'm getting on the escort sites you
know I'm doing it all and I'm just
getting blown up and I'm like this is
great like you just meet with people and
they just [__] give you all this
money and like you know it was new you
know and like I said I liked it I did I
I didn't feel like oh I don't want to be
objectified I liked being objectified I
didn't care I like the attention I liked
all of it it didn't matter like to me it
wasn't anything to me it was fun
um you met some interest you would meet
some interesting people I had you know
well that's that's later but I don't
talk about that right now but um
yeah you meet some interesting people
and um there was this one guy in
particular and he messaged me like I
will pay you to like dominate me and be
a brat and this and that and the other
and I was like I wasn't familiar with
that Kink yet
um coming from Ohio like I was not
familiar with the bratty like dominatrix
type of Kink and he was a good looking
dude and he looked like a dominant dude
and so I was like this guy's gonna chop
me up into [__] pieces and put me in
an oven there's got to be a catch to
this right he's a serial killer that's
what I thought
um but there really was no catch this
dude showed up to my hotel because I was
still stripping and you know doing all
that and I was still in this Motel
like but I was racking up the money so I
was like at peace but anyway so he shows
up to the
he shows up to this hotel and he's like
and I'm like and I'm like step the [__]
back I'm like hold on I'm like hold on
and I wasn't even trying to be a
dominatrix I was just being myself and
he loved it I was like step back I was
like hold the [__] on hold on I was like
um why are you dressing all black you
look like a [__] robber and he's like
I'm sorry goddess like he called me and
God he's like into that it's a kink it's
a yeah I'm sure people a lot of people
know about it but anyways he's into feet
and all kinds of so anyway he steps back
and he kneels down on the ground he's
like I'm sorry goddess and I was like
give me your ID I was like I'm gonna
take a picture of it send it to my dad
send it to my friend so if I go [__]
missing I was like you will
you it'll be on you he's like yes
goddess yes and I was like and I took a
picture of the idiom like all right
we're good I'm like here and I'm like
don't come too close and and it I swear
to God there was no catch with this guy
he did not want me to sleep with them
um I moved into his mansion and I did
become a dominatrix which is not
something I'm into but
it's something that I could easily do
for you know some money at that time
and I lived in the mansion and I took it
over and he slept on the floor
he slept on the [__] floor it was the
most bizarre I I have a really weird
life I don't know why I attract the
weirdest situations but
he's he would sleep on the floor I took
over the master bedroom everything but
again I wanted to touch some fire I
wanted to get into some trouble I wanted
to do
sex work because it was more money and
also
um I wasn't on camera beating men like I
don't want to be and it's you know it's
all over the internet now like I don't
want that all over the Internet like
it's embarrassing it's cringe but like
um anyways so I so eight months into it
I just randomly I found a girl who
wanted a roommate in hot and um in the
middle of Hollywood I'm like okay that's
perfect it was a little shitty whatever
apartment but like it didn't bother me I
was like okay I don't care where I live
because I'm I'm gonna go explore right
so I lived on an air mattress with like
a plastic bin and like I was kind of
just like a floater you know what I mean
I think that goes back to the borderline
thing too like we just kind of don't
have a not having like a core identity
even right now even still to this day I
don't have a core identity and it's kind
of scary
um I don't have a strong sense of self
or identity at all so I kind of just
feel like I'm floating you know what I
mean and so I was a floater I was kind
of like living like a gypsy just
bouncing around
um on dudes couches like just just
bouncing all over the place I would be
at a high-end Mansion one night then the
next day I'd be at the motel six with
like some ratchet random people like you
know what I mean like people who I
didn't even know so like I was just all
over the place and I was having fun but
but I wasn't making money because I was
too caught up in like just
um you know having fun but then I was
like all right gotta get serious and I
swear I manifested this [__] this [__]
is crazy I do believe in manifestation
um
I was really coked out this is like when
I started doing coke so at this point it
was just alcohol and Coke okay that's
how it started I only did alcohol and
coke maybe some Molly every now and then
that's like normal for LA
I feel like everything's normal for La
at this point but like back you know
this was like 2014 2015. so
um so yeah that I was just really coked
out and I was really upset with my life
I was like you know what like why am I
not making money like you know this is
this isn't right like I need money I'm
gonna make it tonight so I get on um
seeking Arrangement which is I'm pretty
sure you know what that is and if I feel
like if you don't know what seeking
Arrangement is like you live under a
rock but like I got a message and they
were they didn't tell me how much but
something like told me like you need to
go I didn't feel like going because I
was hung over
coked out weekend up for 40. I mean like
seriously I did not want to go but
something pushed me to go and I don't
know what the [__] it was but it
happened to be an A-list actor but I
didn't know I was going to an A-list
Doctor's house I was like holy [__] I
didn't know because it because they
don't contact you directly
so I'm just like you know like thinking
it's just like a normal dude and I get
to the gate and they're like what's the
name and I'm like [__] I'm gonna call
the dude I'm like yo I'm like What's
Your Name They said a celebrity's name
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna name them
that might cause a world of problems for
both of us but um
but I was like I couldn't even believe
it because it's like I grew up watching
this guy on TV and [__] you know and I
was like the hell man like
um and and I loved him too and I'm like
no way I'm like I thought they were
[__] with me I thought I thought it
was a prank I was like oh I'm like so I
repeated the name to the lady she's like
give me can I see your ID I'm like yeah
and then
go in and there he [__] is I couldn't
I thought I was dreaming it was trippy I
was like because he was like one of my
favorite actors on TV growing up as a
kid I love them so
um so yeah it was him and we partied we
actually he didn't really care for the
the sex it wasn't about that for him we
talked for eight hours you know it was
fun now were we really [__] up yes I
was I actually smoked that was my first
time smoking uh meth
so I was smoking like a bunch of [__]
and math and honestly math doesn't
affect me surprisingly it calms me down
and makes me relaxed but
um but anyway yeah so that was my first
time doing I'm like it's not like what
people what I picture I pictured myself
like tripping out going in the streets
naked and [__] you know it wasn't like
that at all so we were doing that a lot
of cocaine and a lot of talking
um and he was a really cool dude it was
very easy to hang out with them at first
of course I was intimidated I was scared
I was like [__] man I don't know if I
could live up to this person's standards
but everything went well I ended up
staying for four days and I got a
hundred grand in cash cash
why he would do that in cash I don't
know but I I woke up he was had
mysteriously disappeared
like he would always disappear I don't
know what he was not who knows with
these people
um
but he he disappeared and so I woke up
and then I go to the the party room he
had a little he's a little party Den
room with like a bar it was like pitch
black no windows like it was like the
party room and I'm like what the [__]
where'd he go this is he really not
gonna pay me like what's going on but no
I look and there are 10 envelopes
of 10K and I'm like
just sitting on the chair and no no like
nothing he's just gone I'm like
[__] am I like I'm like what I do I've
never seen money like that in my life I
couldn't believe it imagine if I didn't
go you know what I mean I had a great
time and I got paid
um so that was my first like big
that's when I realized like okay this is
what I'm gonna do like no more stripping
no more that but it did get me
that is what got me into becoming a poly
addict so the first alcohol was always
my main problem and it did cause fatal a
lot of fatal issues
um but I was doing everything like I
said there was one time
where I was just like really [__] up
and I'm like I really just want to try
heroin like why not like I've already
done like you know so I had somebody
shoot me up these people were crazy they
were like
they were hardcore so they didn't like
heroin they liked Fentanyl
they were like what about the Tehran
wasn't good enough for them like they
are like hardcore mother like they were
and think about it like I was already so
drunk and like mixing this too so I was
like I really want to try it like you
know and I [__] hate noodles like I
don't like getting my blood drawn so I
don't know what I was thinking I don't
think I was thinking at all but
um
so yeah they I'm like you do it you do
it you do I'm not doing I'm I'm I can't
do this myself they
prick me and then I'll remember anything
after that and it was fentanyl it was
like pure fentanyl now on top of that it
was probably on top of that but
apparently my friend told me I took like
five bars of Xanax and alcohol so I
don't even know how I lived through that
but I did overdose my face was like
black and blue and I just woke up in the
hospital like just completely [__] up
I was so [__] up I couldn't even
comprehend what the [__] just happened
so
that was my first encounter with
fentanyl and then
after that it's like once you cross that
line it's like anything [__] goes so
on a daily basis it was GHB cocaine
lots of alcohol
like a fifth I'll drink a fifth a day my
nickname was the Handler because I drank
a handle which is like 1.75 liters
that's insane but that's just how much I
drink every day and it was whiskey and
it was like No Chaser warm out of the
bottle
um and so they called me the Handler the
tank all kinds of crazy [__] because I
would do all these drugs I would do
concoction every day it was like meth uh
GHB cocaine
pills if they were there
um Whip It
uh
what other drug is there I probably it's
a crack
I didn't do crack that long though it
was a short-lived thing like I didn't
really care for it but I did do it for a
bit like a couple months crack uh
whatever drug there was I mean I would
just do all of it and I was doing this
[__] on a daily basis for years on top
of being anorexic and bulimic
and I don't even understand like people
are like you're [__] crazy like I
don't know how you're alive I did OD
like 23 times in a year
um so that alone I mean I don't know if
I actually OD'd though I think people
just sent me to the hospital because
they were scared because there wasn't
foam coming out of my mouth I mean I
don't think I actually OD'd I think I
just passed out because I would do that
I would do it at the club if I was like
super high at the club I'd just find a
nice little comfy area and I would just
go like past I would just be like I'm
going to sleep and people would like
think that I overdosed and it's like no
it's just like I'll just sleep and um
and one of my overdoses I escaped the
hospital in the gown
like Barefoot and I ripped the IV on my
arm there's blood all over the sleeve
so it was just real like I just look
crazy my hair my extensions were all
like in a ball on one side of my head
and I went out walking the streets like
that I don't even know like I got an
Uber I called it and the Uber's like are
you okay I look scary you know what I
mean like I look like a crazy person and
like I looked like a threat to society
it was bad and um I was walking the
streets of Hollywood broad daylight
hospital gown covered in blood I look
like it looked like some kind of a
horror film because I'd overdosed I
didn't want to be at the hospital I
wanted to go party again so I was going
up to random cars this is I can't make
this [__] up like this is crazy like I
was going up to random cars because they
were stopping like are you okay it
looked like some crazy [__] and um
they're like are you okay and I'm like
do you want to party
and I was just like they're like um and
like each one of them had an excuse like
one guy was like
um I gotta take my dog to the vet and
like they'd be back in a way I'm like do
you want to party like I was like every
car that stopped like if I was just out
of my [__] mind that day I ended up
passing out on a stranger's
um porch
um covered in blood in a hospital can
you imagine seeing that outside your
door like
it's a it was bad but um I got home and
then yeah it's just like these type of
things just kept going on they just kept
going on and I ended up also in a
situation where I
you know all doing all these drugs you
just get you just don't give a [__]
about anything you don't care what you
look like to people you don't you don't
have it's like I was I was no longer
human I was dehumanized
I was barbaric and I was living on an
animalistic level completely
and I wouldn't it got to the point to
like where I wouldn't shower like
because like I tried to keep my looks
together as much as much as possible I
always I didn't look like a like a
typical I didn't have like fit the
description I wasn't like in the streets
and stuff and that was only because men
because I would live with random guys
and they would think that I was pretty
or whatever so in my mind I'm thinking
no pretty
homeless no pretty no free drugs no
pretty
uh what's the third one
no pretty no money
because I was my only source of income
so I thought that you know at that point
living barbarically like that yes that
was the only thing I had to offer to
make any sort of living and so I always
kept my [__] together and nobody nobody
knew and except the people I was doing
it with like what I was like actually
doing you wouldn't look at me and say
hey that girl's a [__] drug like you
know what I mean so when I would tell
people like yeah I just smoke crack like
I went on a Tinder date with a guy and I
had a crack rock in my pocket I'm not
even kidding and he's like a square and
I didn't really like him anyway so I
just kind of wanted to scare him a
little bit I wasn't clicking with him
and he's like uh
I was like hey I have a crack Rack in my
pocket can I go smoke in your bathroom
and he's like what he's like you're
joking I'm like I'm really not
I'm like I'm not I'm not I'm not joking
and he's like uh he's like what the he's
like no he's like you're joking I'm like
I'm not [__] joking does it look like
I'm joking I looked him right into his
eyes and uh I just wanted to scare him
on purpose because I didn't like him
that much but um
but yeah I uh just just lots of
craziness and then
I actually was clinically dead
so that's that was when so okay let's
I'm getting too ahead of myself here
there's so much [__] like it's like a
jumbled up mess but like by age 24 I had
early stage cirrhosis
well they told me scarring on my liver
so I assume that's what that means but
at the time I didn't know what that
meant I'm like oh well yeah I'm scarring
on my liver I'm [__] of course I do I
didn't think it meant I didn't know what
it meant it's like no you need to take
this seriously and even at 21 they said
if you keep doing this [__] like you're
gonna be dead by age 22. age 21 I woke
up in a different state
not knowing how I got there no
recollection whatsoever I woke up in
Chicago I don't know anybody in Chicago
what and everything I owned was with me
and that was my first DT experience from
alcohol at 21. I for that's a big that
was one of the scariest things I've ever
went through was like DTS I'd rather get
stabbed
I'd rather get like shot
and I have been shot before I have a
gunshot wound right here I can't show it
on camera because then you know but um
I woke up in a different state this is
this is where alcohol and drugs bring
you like this is where this is what
happens like I woke up in a different
state not knowing why I got there and I
still didn't think I had a problem with
alcohol and drugs
my solution was to go get a drink and
figure it out
that was my so that's the insanity I
mean like seriously and it didn't end
there that was 21. I'm 28 now
you know what I mean and I still
struggle you know with it but
yeah basically I went [__] nuts I
didn't know what DTS were I didn't know
you can withdraw from alcohol so I
thought that I died and went to hell
and I was freaking out they called The
Looney Bin because they thought I was
schizophrenic
I wasn't schizophrenic it was just
alcohol DTs my nervous system was
shutting down I was hallucinating
um
and this is something I don't like to
tell people but I'm gonna
only like two people know this this is
so embarrassing but I got it fixed so
it's okay but
in the Looney Bin I was in such hardcore
DTS that
um I hallucinated the Grim Reaper okay I
kept hallucinating the groomer group and
all kinds of other crazy [__] that's a
whole other [__] thing
um and the Grim Reaper was taunting me
telling me what to do and I would do it
thinking like they were gonna slit my
throat like it was it I mean I know I
know I sound crazy but this is alcohol
DTs I mean if you talk to a lot of
people who've been through it that's
what happens that's what you see
um you see things like that and it told
me I had to knock my teeth out okay this
is in the Loon event it told me
this is all you know my imagination this
was all psychosis
um but I thought it was real so
it told me to knock my front teeth out
and I did it I swear to God I [__]
did it I woke up they gave me volume
because they finally realized like okay
she's not crazy her hands are tremoring
and she's an alcohol withdrawal this was
at 21 years old I'd only been drinking
for like
what's that like four years but it was
like the quantities you know you drink a
handle a day I mean you could be
dependent within like months you know
but um they wouldn't sell me any more
alcohol that's the only reason I stopped
drinking the hotel that I was in they're
like no they're like you woke up in a
different state like we're not giving
you anything
and I was like all right whatever and I
just go upstairs and you know the DT
started slowly and then they progressed
into something real beastly and I just
lost my [__] mind and so anyways yeah
Looney band wake up
my four it's not it's not like I
literally like plied my teeth out it's
like I just kind of knocked him on the
sink so like
these like three your Forefront teeth
were like chipped out they weren't like
fully out of my skull but like they were
like not the [__] like and I was like oh
my God and I didn't know what was going
on I still at this point did not know
what DTS were you know what I mean I had
no idea what DTS were
um so I didn't know what was going on I
thought maybe I could be schizophrenic
out of nowhere I thought maybe someone
had drugged me
um I I just really didn't know I was
deranged completely and
um I then finally the the um the workers
at the mental hospital explained to me
like you're not crazy you drink a lot
and you were experiencing alcohol
withdrawal or they told me DTS and I was
like what are DTS is that a disease like
I thought it was like a disease or
something and they were like no it's
it's when you drink a lot of alcohol and
you can actually die from quitting I'm
like you can die from quitting drinking
like that's absurd they're like yeah
well if you drink enough like they're
like how much do you drink I'm like
I don't know maybe around a gallon of
liquor I mean like you know and I
wouldn't puke either it was it was just
crazy so I just you know my life was
good I was making money and everything
and all of a sudden this [__] happens
it's like it all flipped and turned on
me in one night and that's when I knew
alcohol was like my biggest problem
all the other stuff like I you know
I would do everything else but like
alcohol definitely brought me to the
lowest bottoms
um in 2022
I would say death is the lowest bottom I
don't know what do you think
it's real low yeah I so
April or was April or May late April May
2022 I had taken a street
um Xanax I was like okay we're just
gonna have a little mini party I'm only
gonna drink a little bit of this bottle
I'm only gonna have a little bit you
know and it ended up being like I drank
a [__] fifth of Captain Morgan and
took this
pressed Xanax that was pure Fentanyl and
luckily I had a roommate
um who you know found me I had a
roommate who found me and there was foam
coming out of my mouth
and I had a bloody nose
and I was clinically dead
and which is weird because I don't
remember any of this I just woke up in
the hospital they double narcanned me
um and four days after that I'm buying a
bottle of alcohol I mean it's just like
[__] crazy I mean I just I just can't
like
I just I I don't I it's just like the
end there there's not there's not like
it's pure Insanity like it just doesn't
make any sense I don't even make sense
to myself yesterday even I've been sober
um from everything
for today's day 11.
so that's the only reason I'm able to
even have a conversation right now but
today's day 11 I'm sober from everything
um what's what's your motivation for
getting
getting clean
um
well this sounds bad but one is like
vanity I don't want to age
readily
I'm getting older like I can't be like
in and two it's just like I hate the
person that I am when I'm drinking and
when I'm drugging
um actually the drugs don't affect me
I'm fine on the drugs but I don't want I
don't really care for them anymore
alcohol like I said was my number one
poison of choice and it calls me all the
issues I didn't have any issues from
anything else except PCP that [__] made
me act crazy I almost got sent to jail
okay but that's it makes everyone crazy
yeah oh no I never no that was like a
one-time thing like you know what I mean
uh that [__] was weird
um and I did it at a spa around like
normal people so um yeah that was bad
but um
so yeah the motivation for being clean
is that like my life quality is better I
do get bored
sometimes but it's just caused me so
many bottoms how many bottoms can you
hit I mean you've died you know you've
got sent to the line event oh and I've
woken up in jail in different states
before as well not knowing what the [__]
I did or how I got there how do I how
they let me on planes I don't even I
have no recollection I have a warrant
for my arrest in Texas and Indiana and
luckily I'll never go to any of those
places
I kind of like Texas a little bit but
but no I have warrants for my arrest in
Texas I have no recollection of
disorderly conduct is this all a product
of you being borderline
I think so yeah that's why because I
talked to oh and uh at 26 I got
diagnosed with bipolar II
I don't even know what that is I don't
even want to look at it I don't want to
hear a lot of guys dream girl
oh God no no
um but yeah um bipolar too and as well
as borderline
um and I was like no I'm not bipolar but
they're like no you're sporadic like
um behaviors that you do that's bipolar
to behavior but it is also borderline
Behavior too
just going on random like because like I
said like not having like a strong sense
of identity it could feel like the Earth
is being like ripped from underneath my
feet sometimes like I'm not grounded I
don't know what the [__] to do like I
don't
have like that core
that strong core sense of like anything
really so that it's just like with that
I'm just kind of like a Loose Cannon and
I don't like being medicated you know
what I mean I don't want to take the
medication why so I could be a zombie I
mean I'd rather be unhinged and crazy
and I'm crazy sober
so I don't [__] need to do all that I
can still be healthy and be crazy at the
same time like I'm I'm nuts enough as it
is sober I don't need all this [__] to
to have fun so it's like at this point
I'm thinking like you know
that [__] makes me miserable at this
point and I think it's because I'm older
now you know what I mean my body is just
kind of rejecting all of it the last
time I did like a heart like a harder
drug like something other than alcohol
was on October I smoked some meth on
Halloween of 2022. yeah only because
like my girlfriend she's she's not my
friend anymore but of course you know
I've literally had 19 friends
um pass away in the last like two years
from drugs
so I mean and I've lost a lot of them
because they're just fake and you know
what I mean that's what happens that's
another
um inspiration for like getting you know
clean
um you know want to attract better
things into my life and the and the
number one thing is here's my reasoning
my number one reasoning is because I
always want I always had this idea in my
head like I wanted it all like I have
big goals I have like all these this
ideals that I want out of life and I can
get them but I also wanted to get [__]
up at the same time and I also wanted to
get crazy delusional at the same time
and have all of this and it's like you
you can't have both
and it's a hard pill to swallow because
I it's so fun to just have a drink and
just get [__] loose and lit and just
go insane it's fun you are who does I
mean like you are a lot of guys dream
girl
oh God yeah
I've woken up in random dudes cars
before I don't even know whose cars but
anyways yeah I um
there was like this quote I'm not gonna
take credit I was gonna try and take
credit for this quote but I'm not going
to because it's [__] up and I'm sure
you've probably heard it before anyway
but it's like trade in one thing for
everything or wait give up one thing for
everything or give up everything for one
thing or something and when I heard that
I was like yeah that's pretty much where
my head's at and then I thought that you
know
even though there's a lot of other
stories but but I mean I thought it
would be interesting to come on here
because I relate to a lot of the people
who I've seen on here on on your channel
like I can't remember his name but he
said he was a nihilist and a sex addict
that's a whole group of yes a lot of
them that could be anybody but anyways I
I've related to a lot of people on here
and I'm like you know what like them
sharing their story and the thing is
like I don't I was never like homeless I
was never on the streets but it doesn't
mean I wasn't like stuff like going
through oh you're just a different part
of that the only reason just because I
could get myself together and I would
like just live with random dudes you
know what I mean
there were so many times where I would
just meet random dudes and like I didn't
even know them and they would be like
you can come live with me do you see men
as
ways to buy stability in your life or
just money
um not all of them no but when when
you've done sex work and stuff and
you've been like spoiled and because
I've never I don't I don't want to make
anyone else feel bad because I have seen
stories on here where girls have had a
really hard
um time with with sex work
um and I feel for them really bad
because I haven't experienced that I I
had a good run with it so when you've
been spoiled like that with like in sex
work
um
and you've made so much money I've had
three
A-list actors hire me not directly
obviously but through people and they
all like to get [__]
you would never guess these these people
like what they do like it's absolutely
[__] crazy like they all love meth I
don't know why it's like a thing I don't
know why like rich people love meth it's
so weird
um like these these actors you would
never guess what they do and I'll never
tell because I'm afraid they'll kill me
but um
but
um but yeah it's just like when you're
spoiled in that department you do kind
of view relationships differently things
like that
um could you possibly even settle down
with one guy who's nice to you and
you're nice to him and everything's
smelling I have before
um I
I went my whole time in LA without
having one boyfriend and it's not that I
didn't have it's not that nobody wanted
to date me it's just like I just was
kind of focused on like making money and
also I was very [__] up it's like I
love drugs more than I loved anything
else you've been in love before huh
you've been in love before yeah yeah one
time
yeah and um
so yeah when you're spoiled in the in
the sex work departments it is hard to
like date because the guy like you can
find a cool guy and he'll be like he'll
say like oh they always say like oh I
don't care what you do I met you like
this but that's not how it goes you know
what I mean that's not the way it plays
out what does it turn out so the last
time that this happened to me every time
it's happened to me actually this is how
it goes with every guy and this has
happened a million times I don't care
what you do I know what you do like I
met you like this I don't care and then
um you will you know
be like okay I'm going to go work and
then like they'll start to get kind of
an attitude you know like I read people
very well I said pick up on Vibes and
I'm like oh man The Vibes are just so
wrong right now like they're not happy
they're not gonna admit it yet but
they're not happy and then eventually
it'll be like I don't want you escorting
then they will try to control me and
then they'll try to keep me in a box and
you know
um I'm just not like that I've never
been like that though even before sex
works so it's
you don't like to be controlled
no I don't I mean like maybe for like
role play or something but like not in
real life
like I like to kind of like have I like
to be in control of my of everything
pretty much
like you know what I mean and so that's
that's another reason to get soap that
I'm getting sober well in the pros I'm
only 11 days I mean who knows who knows
what could happen I'm not gonna promise
anybody anything but that's another uh
motivator for me to get sober I'm a
control freak sometimes a lot
and I think because I'm a control freak
it makes me want to lose control if that
makes sense so like being a control
freak and just wanting everything like
exactly a type of way it
it could just
another quote
another quote I'm not going to take
credit for it but one of the A-list
actors that I hung out with I don't know
if he stole this quota if he made it up
himself but he was like the most I was
like why do you do all these things like
You're so successful you're so like
you're you were my idol like as a kid I
watched you growing up like you know why
do you smoke crack why do you do all
this [__] you know and he was like the
most powerful people like to lose
control and that sat with me like
forever that makes sense you know you
just want to you just you get so OCD and
crazy and then you just want to just
lose you know and the best way to do
that drugs and alcohol especially
alcohol makes me the most delusional out
of any drug I've ever done
even PCP I was more functional in PCP
than Apple like alcohol just makes me I
could not come on here today on alcohol
you tell me probably like this isn't
going to work out like you gotta go but
guess what I was nervous to come on here
because I've never been on camera before
or even done photo shoots or anything
um so yesterday I was literally trying
to find like a way to get alcohol like
but then I was like no because of this
interview yeah because my nerves were a
little but no I'm comfortable now but
like my nerves were just I didn't know
what I was gonna walk into or if there
were going to be a lot of people you
know what I mean so even yesterday I was
thinking about it you know what I mean
it's always kind of like a demon it's
like something you you have to like deal
with you know I feel like I don't know
if it's ever gonna go away it's kind of
like anorexia and bulimia which I've had
but I quit bulimia cool turkey in 2017
or 2018.
um
because one of my girlfriends had passed
away she was a bulimic alcoholic and she
was only 20. and she was beautiful
and that's all that's her own that was
her only poison though was alcohol and
bulimia and she passed away in a very
nasty way and um she was only 20 years
old so not even of the drinking so that
motivated me to at least quit bulimia
but I still didn't quit the alcohol
um what happened 100 Grand that huh what
happened to the 100 Grand that the uh
actor gave you
oh the hundred grand oh this is great
thank you thank you see I forget my own
[__]
um
um so you just opened a whole other door
so I started dating a heroin addict in
2017 to 2018. he was living on the
streets but I thought it was kind of
sexy for some reason
I don't know where my head was at that
time but I thought it was sexy like that
he was like because he was good looking
but he was like rugged and like you know
like he just was like a bad boy and like
he uh he did he did heroin meth I mean
he was a poly addict as well but his
main poison was heroin and Fentanyl
um and I dated him and I literally
thought I was so in love and I think it
was the mess meth makes me think
everyone's so much better than what they
are because three days off a meth I
looked at him and I was like I don't
think I like you anymore you know like
it's just like weird like three days off
meth I'm like no so anyways I was off
the meth for three days because I could
I could quit like heroin and okay I did
get heroin let's draw that [__] sucks
but it didn't suck more than alcohol
withdrawal so after if you go through
alcohol GT's I feel like you can get
through any withdrawal because I feel
like it's the worst one but that's just
my opinion
um so I just got off the method and I
looked at him kind of funky I was like
this whole thing has been like stupid
and I was also sober from alcohol too
for three days and I was just like what
the [__] am I doing I don't have to live
like this I have a home
I never let him in though I didn't trust
him
you know what I mean I just didn't trust
him because he had stolen from other
people so I'm like well I don't know
what the plan wants you in my place I
had designer [__] like I'm like no
however I've never
picture you to be a drug addict or
alcoholic
everybody says that everybody [__]
says that and that's another reason I
got away with a lot of [__] because
because like because I'm not in an
alleyway
you know clean yeah because I'm not an
Alleyway like you know like
all bunker down like they they nobody
everyone would like laugh like they they
didn't really take it serious and I was
kind of I kind of had like a cry for
help but I'm not the type to like put my
problems on other people so I kind of
hid it
um but yeah I never looked like like a
junkie I don't like saying that word I
don't I don't mean offense to any to
anybody but I never had that look I
never looked like that I haven't had a
client as an escort one time tell me he
was like um if you he's like if you um
if you want to tell me he's like dude
he's like you look like a Disney PR he
said I look like a Disney princess and
this was like in the midst of like my
worst like at doing everything he's like
you look like a Disney princess he's
like I can't believe you you know you're
doing all these I'm like yeah yeah dude
I'm like yeah it's really bad I'm having
a hard time you know it's I'm like and I
was stuck in a constant cycle of
addiction mainly with alcohol the other
stuff I could live without but the
alcohol I felt like I couldn't stop and
it got to the point where I was puking
blood every day
that is not good I was internally
bleeding at one point which is like
also I almost went to a coma my blood
sugar dropped to like 38 so if you know
anything about blood sugar
anything below like 50 I think or
something is like coma like you go into
a coma I didn't go and do a coma though
but I was puking one day I went to go
vomit regular all day like just puking
you know 12 hours I mean like that's
just how I spent it's being an alcoholic
honestly alcohol was the most miserable
dysfunctional Insidious addiction out of
all of them out of every every one of
them even heroin even like all of them
alcohol was the most Insidious
horrible miserable terrible [__]
addiction and I mean God I I mean so I
would be puking blood and one day I went
to go puke and it was just like a normal
day
pure dark red came out I just puked pure
[__] blood and I wanted to still keep
drinking after that that's how addicted
I was I was terrified to go through the
withdrawals and I was just in this
constant cycle where either I was really
[__] up and and I did get pretty nasty
I mean it would get nasty I'd be covered
and pissed I would start peeing myself
uh covered in vomit you ever been
suicidal no
no no
I I I mean there was a time though in
life if this makes sense I wasn't so
afraid of dying I was more afraid of
waking up because I had put myself in
such a [__] up position and the
hardest pill to swallow of all of it is
that you do it all to your damn self and
like it's like what it's very hard to
sit with yourself you know and be like I
did this I created this hell you know
and so with the alcohol that day when I
puked all that blood
I didn't I wanted to keep getting drunk
now my roommate cared about me
and she had hidden my credit card and
she knew I wouldn't go out in public to
buy
more booze because my hair was [__] up
and I'm always all crazy about my hair
and you know everything and so she's
like she knew that like okay she's not
gonna go buy alcohol in public with
looking like that
and she's not she's not um well enough
to get up to do her hair or to do her
makeup so she took my [__] ID and my
credit card
and I couldn't order more alcohol
and I was like [__] because she saw the
blood I forgot to flush the toilet or
something I don't know but she saw that
and it scared the [__] out of her and so
I'm like Simon's this was like oh this
was kind of a bottom moment this is this
was weird I'd seen people drink hand
sanitizer before on like TLC shows and
all this crazy [__] I'd seen people
drink mouthwash and I'm like oh man
those people were crazy
no I [__] went there I went to the
bathroom and I just stared there was
hand sanitizer there's mouthwash and I
just stared I'm like
and I just I just sat and had like some
stuff that's just I'm like all right
let's hit them we're about to hit rock
bottom I don't give a [__] because I I
didn't wanna I was already going through
the DTs were coming I could feel it I'm
like I'm no no I can't do this I can't
do it so I just took the mouthwash and I
just chugged like half a bottle of
[__] mouthwash that did not go well
that came right back out like I was like
okay let's hold it in let's hold it in
let's hold it in didn't get held in and
I just like all out and I'm like [__] so
then so then the mouthwash was out of
the question I'm like I'm digging
through the house looking through like
just an inkling of something digging
digging flipping [__] all over the place
it's a desire to get [__] up yeah I
needed some alcohol I needed something
even though I just puked blood I did not
I couldn't stand the withdrawals it was
just it was just I I just I'd rather
like
it's like I would do anything like to
get my hand it's not that I wanted to
keep drinking it's it's it's like I was
desperate to not feel the withdrawal so
like I was digging through the house I
was flipping [__] apart I was screaming
bloody murder
and then I went to the hand sanitizer
and I stared at it just like I stared at
the mouthwash and I was like
and I drank hand sanitizer and so I was
like oh okay
and the hand sanitizer it just I passed
out I didn't puke but I'm sure it's not
healthy that's the only time I've done
that actually and it was it was just
like a desk it was like a kind of like a
desperate moment like you know my
roommate took my [__] from me and I'm
like and I texted her all these
paragraphs I'm like you stupid [__]
like I hate you like you know but on the
plus side
through all of this craziness I was
never a person who
um I was never like a junkie or whatever
the hell you want to call it yeah I was
a drunk at one point I just didn't look
like one so people don't didn't call me
one and I don't think that's fair
because addiction does not discriminate
trust me I've seen some really attract
like the a-listers that would hire me
they are [__] up they do more than a
lot of people that go on on your show so
it doesn't discriminate but anyways
um
what was I saying
what was I saying oh no throughout
throughout all of this
um I was never a steal I was never a
thief I've never stolen one thing from
anybody I was never I lied a lot of God
I was a [__] liar but mainly I lied
about my sobriety
mainly that's what I lied about I would
lie and say I was sober all the time
because I can get away with it but if I
was drinking like you'd know I was
drinking but on the other drugs you
wouldn't be able to tell I could be on
drugs right now you wouldn't know it
really really but I'm not I swear I
swear on my Dad's life
on the way here because it gives me kind
of a little alcohol but I love it 11
days sober does the does the prospect of
continuing with this scare you
um no yeah no I mean I think at this
point I've ran myself so [__] ragged
my last relapse
it was it's just so destructive I just
like it's like I tell myself I'll have
one and it's like come on man it's been
11 years of you doing this if you could
figure out a way to drink normally you
would have done it by now there is no
way for me to drink normally there's no
way for me to do anything like that
normally I'm gluttonous when it comes to
substances and alcohol I will just
is it just something in your DNA did
somebody in your family um yeah
addiction runs on both sides and this is
something that I didn't really want to
say
because it is my dad and I love him so
much and I don't I'm not trying to like
make him look bad because he he's my
favorite person in the world he was
never a drunk he never really I mean he
would have a drink every now and then
but like you know you couldn't tell you
have a beer every now and then like
normal as [__]
um he's my favorite person on the planet
my rock everything like he's he's always
been like a positive positivity in my
life you know what I mean